MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Today, we're talking
about Anthos and AWS, supporting
health care providers,
and Google Cloud training.
I'm Mark, and welcome
to this week in Cloud,
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
Anthos was announced
with an ambitious goal
to enable portability
for applications
across your multi-cloud
or hybrid infrastructure.
Over the past year, we've been
working hard and expanding
support for multi-cloud,
and we've just
graduated AWS support
to generally available.
We'll continue to provide
flexible Cloud computing
solutions so that your
business can grow and adapt
to whatever comes its way.
As the health care industry
is pushed to its limits,
we're focusing on offering
support and solutions
wherever we can.
From offering HIPAA compliant
telehealth services with Google
Meet, to providing Google
Cloud research credits,
and hosting a free repository
of public health care data sets.
And finally, we've released
our Cloud health care
API as generally available
to help organizations
ingest and manage key data
from a variety of systems.
Cloud Spanner provides a
scalable, multi-version
database with
relational semantics.
We've just introduced
managed backup-restore
to provide data protection with
minimal management overhead.
These restores are
optimized for data access,
meaning that you can access
terabytes of restore data
within minutes of a failure.
Check out the post to learn more
and to see other new features
in Spanner.
When it comes to
Google Cloud training,
we focused on creating content
for all learning styles,
from self-paced courses to
instructor-led workshops.
While in-person learning
isn't possible right now,
we're focusing on creating
virtual classrooms.
Check out Cloud
training to learn more
about enrolling
in a virtual class
and to see all of
the courses we offer.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.